[Applause]
even though we are the ones standing
here and climate environmental and human
rights activists all over the world are
being prosecuted sometimes convicted and
given legal penalties for acting in line
with science we must remember who the
real enemy is what are we defending who
are our laws meant to
protect a crime it protest is not a
crime
[Music]
prot it's great to have Greta come to
the UK and take part in protests here
because that really attracts more
attention to the issue um her case is
far from unique there are so many more
going through the courts right now uh
people who have done very similar things
to her just literally uh standing on the
street or on the pavement exercising
their right to protest um refusing to
move when the police have asked them to
and then facing really severe penalties
for that it's
not history judgment against those who
deliberately destroy and sacrifice the
planet resources at the expense of
humanity at the expense of all those who
are suffering the consequences of the
environmental and climate crisis already
today and at the expense of future
Generations your own children and
grandchildren will not be gentle power
is literally cogenic there's good tool
kits to fix it quick
people